mit ihren zwei Eimern drängt sich Mavis
mochlongo nach vorne in die erste Reihe
sie ist wütend auf die Politiker auf die
Stadt weil seit Tagen kein Wasser mehr
aus ihrer Leitung kommt
[Musik]
das ist die zweite Woche die zweite
Woche ohne Wasser
Trucks liefern Wasser in die Vororte von
Johannesburg es ist viel zu wenig für so
viele die darauf angewiesen sind
manchmal muss Mavis kilometerweit laufen
heute hat sie Glück gehabt
frikas Infrastruktur kollabiert
Stromausfälle gehören zum Alltag und
ohne Strom für die Wasserpumpen bleiben
auch Wasserhähne und Toilettenspülungen
trocken
wir können uns selbst nicht waschen
sogar die Kinder gehen nicht mehr zur
Schule wegen des Wassermangels die
Kinder hier sollten eigentlich in der
Schule sein
das Netz wurde über Jahrzehnte
vernachlässigt die Kraftwerke sind
marode Gelder zur Wartung flossen auf
Privatkonten von Managern und Politikern
das Land hat zu wenig Strom und kappt
die Versorgung oft bis zu zehn Stunden
verteilt über den Tag
die Folgen erlebt die Lokalpolitikerin
Lerato und pefo jeden Tag wieder ein
zerstörter Stromkasten den Techniker
reparieren müssen bei Problemen ist sie
oft die erste die angerufen wird
die Kabel wurden gestohlen das ist
Vandalismus jemand hat die Kabel
durchtrennt und sie mitgenommen
Kabel die benutzen die geplanten
Stromausfälle für ihre Beutezüge sogar
Erdkabel werden ausgegraben das Kupfer
ist begehrt für die betroffenen
Haushalte ist das eine Katastrophe statt
Stunden kann es Tage dauern bis das
Problem behoben wird
egal was man im Kühlschrank hat das
Essen verdirbt ich weiß nicht was die
Tierklinik neben an 24 Stunden ohne
Elektrizität macht
Lerato nimmt uns mit zum benachbarten
tierkrankenhaus indem wir Besitzerin
Wendy Davis treffen alles ist dunkel die
Ersatzbatterien sind längst aufgebraucht
es war ein Albtraum überhaupt
jemanden zu erreichen
weil niemand weiß wie lange der Strom
ausbleibt haben sie erstmal alle
Operationen abgesagt
wenn ein Hund geröntgt oder operiert
werden muss können wir das nicht leisten
aus unserer Perspektive ist das wirklich
nicht fair
zwei Katzen mit Diabetes sind noch da
für ihre Spritzen braucht Wendy keinen
Strom die sechs Hunde die noch am Morgen
bei ihr waren hat sie mit einer
Tierambulanz in die nächste Klinik
geschickt
wir hatten ein paar Fälle mit
Gallenkoliken die am tropfingen wenn man
Tiere am Tropf hat und dann keinen Strom
das funktioniert leider nicht das sind
wohl mit Blaulicht geht es im Konvoi
durch die Townships von Prätoria wir
begleiten den polizeischiff bei einer
nächtlichen Streife die wohl vor allem
Präsenz demonstrieren soll Kabel Diebe
werden nicht gefasst dafür aber eine
illegale Bar hochgenommen seitdem die
Stromausfälle zunehmen ist auch die
Kriminalität weiter gestiegen
das hat schon einen Einfluss
insbesondere die Einbrüche in
Geschäftsgebäude haben zugenommen die
Kriminellen nutzen die Dunkelheit aus
der Staat ist überfordert nach drei
Jahrzehnten Alleinherrschaft ist das
Vertrauen in Nelson Mandelas einst so
stolze Befreiungsbewegung zerstört im
Regierenden African National Congress
sei Korruption weit verbreitet in
Staatsunternehmen würden zahlreiche
Personen sitzen die öffentliche Gelder
missbrauchen sagt timbermasseko
ST
es werden Unternehmen beauftragt die für
ihre Aufgaben nicht geeignet sind und
die Auftraggeber erwarten dafür dann
noch Schmiergelder
am Ende bleiben dann nur sehr wenige
Ressourcen übrig um die notwendige
Infrastruktur auch wirklich zu liefern
als Whistleblower hat er den früheren
Präsidenten Jacob suma auf die
Anklagebank gebracht er wurde zum
Staatsfeind erklärt musste um sein Leben
fürchten und verlor seinen Job als
Regierungssprecher heute lehrt er als
politikprofessor in Johannesburg bei den
Wahlen im nächsten Jahr sagt er könnte
der AMC erstmals die absolute Mehrheit
verlieren
es wundert mich überhaupt nicht dass die
Zivilgesellschaft in vielen Teilen des
Landes anfängt sich selbst zu
organisieren es ist ein deutliches
Zeichen dafür dass die Menschen das
Vertrauen in die politische Struktur und
das System verlieren
Song geso sibi will mit seiner
politischen Bewegung eine Alternative
anbieten
Reisen sansi steh auf Südafrika eine
junge und diverse Generation drängt
darauf die politische Kultur zu
verändern die Mehrheit im Land ist nach
der Apartheid aufgewachsen hat genug von
Korruption und den Seilschaften Alter
Eliten
wir sind dabei ein Fail state zu werden
und eine der Gründe warum wir uns
entschieden haben die Bewegung zu
gründen und Südafrika zu modernisieren
ist zu verhindern ein Fail state zu
werden
mehr Transparenz mehr Zivilgesellschaft
es sind viele wohlklingende Worte und
doch grundlegend für den Glauben an die
Demokratie es ist viel von
Aufbruchstimmung die Rede von Mitsprache
für Südafrikas junge Gesellschaft denn
gerade bei den Jungen singt die
Wahlbeteiligung seit Jahren
was wir verloren haben ist größer als
Politik es geht um Vertrauen als Anker
für die südafrikanische Gesellschaft
ohne das wird nichts funktionieren und
was wir anbieten ist eine Vision die
Gemeinschaft wieder zu stärken
zurück zu meVis die ihre zwei Eimer
Wasser vom Truck nach Hause schleppt für
die Enkel wird sie gleich essen kochen
ihr jüngster Sohn konnte es kaum noch
erwarten
ich hasse die Regierung und diejenigen
die das Geld eigentlich an die Menschen
weitergeben sollten ich hasse sie weil
sie es in ihrer eigenen Taschen stecken
morgen wird sie wieder Wasser holen mit
jedem Tag den ihr Wasserhahn trocken
bleibt wächst bei Mavis der Ärger
[Musik]